[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are talking about
10 people
that we are jealous of
each so potentially 20 unless there's
crossover there might be crossover i
don't know we don't reveal these lists
to each other i don't know your list but
i feel like we're going to be jealous of
the same people it might be a hundred
percent crossover what if that happened
i'd be people would be so jealous
of us well i
the reason i don't think that's gonna
happen is because um this wasn't as
this wasn't as easy or even though like
coming up with like your favorite
artists or your favorite albums or
whatever it's not easy but
there's a narrow field it's like i'm
choosing from albums
when you're choosing from anyone that
you can be jealous of it's like well
there's people you can be jealous of
people for all kinds of different
reasons as i think
i tried to
capture in the list yeah the when we did
the top 10 inspirations
it kind of
as i started to think about it momentum
started to build
and a ranking a loose ranking started to
take form with this it's more like well
i don't know if this is good for my
mental health but i think it is just to
put it out there just put out the
jealousy and just kind of put it in its
place but then i started having trouble
coming up with
specific people and i'm like wow
maybe i'm just maybe i'm not that
jealous but then i'm like you know what
i'm just not i'm just not thinking of
everybody i bet rhett's gonna jog my
memory and i'm gonna be like man i'm a
jealous person well i i don't see i i
guess i didn't take this as the negative
side of jealousy which obviously
jealousy is not good in general but
people who have something there's some
aspect of their lives that i would like
to have in my life yeah that's how i
that's how i went about this i think it
really hits home there's a couple on my
list that like the sweet spot for me is
i could see that it could be me or i
want it to be me and so there's like
actual
jealousy of like man i
i'm
almost i'm envious
of what this person has is doing or is
able to do because i feel like i should
be in that person's position
well there's a few of those i don't
think there's anybody on my list that i
actually feel like i could aspire to all
right well in one one qualifier
that we did discuss ahead of time we
didn't put each other on each other's
lists yeah yeah yeah okay so
because we could do a whole
episode about things that we're jealous
of each other about
um
i'm not saying we're going to
it might be a good episode idea i think
it is like an episode idea and like the
long list of episode ideas speaking of
episode ideas last week boy i had had a
fun time listening to those voicemails
one eight eight eight earpod one
listen up
when you are listening to us right now
and you have some sort of reaction i
want you to call that number and leave a
verbal reaction
i would love to be able to put
uh reactions to the episode at the end
of episodes
if we get enough good ones just like
it's kind of a closing credits thing
reaction to the previous episode the
previous yeah like that would be
impossible
yeah the previous episode uh
i used to listen to a podcast called
sound opinions a lot i've fallen out of
it sometimes i go back to it depending
on what albums they're reviewing
um
but they do that at the end of their
podcast and i always like it oh i love
the voicemails yeah and even the
reactions to the previous episode
montage at the end specifically what i'm
talking about yeah i like that too 1888
earpod one
now
in that episode we pushed something we
were going to talk about at the
beginning that i think you've totally
forgotten about but i remember and i
think we can make it into a whole
episode as early as next week
you remember
i do i do but then i thought we talked
about the fight that we had instead of
talking about the thing that you had on
your laptop which i don't want to reveal
but youth involving lyrics you think we
can make oh you think we can make a
whole episode out of
lyrics well no we didn't tell people
what it was so i don't want to give it
away but like okay
because i thought we there was two
episode ideas in that oh one was talking
about
which i'll just go ahead and say this
one because we're not going to do it now
because i the story
started with me
uh
the fact that shepard is going to like a
middle school dance and lock is going to
prom oh not that yeah
and i was like well we can't do that now
because everybody's will have gone to
their dances and their problems but
until so next year when we're getting
remember the dance season because i got
lots of great dad advice about both of
these yeah we'll have to events we'll
have to we'll have to hit that and uh in
the next dance and shepherd because
chevrolet started asking me was like
what what was your middle school dance
like and i said oh you have
you've asked your dad a great question
so
which led to you wanting to talk about
the lyrics to a specific song that we
were into at that age that i played for
him on the way into school now reading
it back it's like so i think that
analysis of the lyrics that went over
our heads
as middle schoolers is a good idea
maybe as early as next week maybe as
early as next week let us know hashtag
your biscuits let us know what lyrics
from songs went over your head as a kid
i'm making this a prompt do it now oh
gosh and then maybe in the next episode
but probably not and then i don't know
how the timing works probably not in the
next episode but it's true probably two
episodes from now let's get on our list
do you want to go first of who you're
jealous of you want me to go first you
go first you want to rock paper scissors
you go first i can hit you with a banger
using the parlance of
this person
and if somebody's number as my first one
if somebody on your list uh is better
than i'm more jealous of somebody on
your list i have to choose somebody on
my list to knock off
vice versa oh really fine yeah so the
episode
like withers away the ending of the
episode
dissolves no obstacles we'll still talk
about all of them but you know oh but
they'll go off of the list
i've had i wasn't really precious about
the order and matter of fact this is my
number nine that i'm not making my
number 10 because i want to hit you with
this
okay because i think this is this one's
this one's real this is one of those
ones that like i feel a little
uncomfortable putting out there
oh i'm just gonna do it
uh
i am freaking jealous of mr beast
oh okay see yeah i didn't think about it
you know
freaking mr beast man
now
i i've had it i've had a one-on-one i've
had a personal phone conversation with
jimmy
you know did you tell the person
the person behind mr beast it's
it's been
it might have been a year ago well yeah
it was definitely in pandemic times
and okay you may be saying well why are
you jealous of mr beast of course
because he's like so
he's popping because he's on the cover
of a rolling stone that's why
dude got on the cover of a magazine that
gets delivered to my house i don't want
you know
i
i like i like getting the rolling stone
magazine
i like i mean
i've had this secret dream what if you
know it's it's one of those iconic
things to be on the cover of the rolling
stone there's even a song about it
being on the cover of the rolling stone
and i don't want another creator
coming on coming on a magazine in my
home
that didn't sound right
yeah i definitely don't want that i
don't want i don't want another creator
showing up depending on the type of
magazine
that can't happen on a freaking
magazine cover that i enjoy
man it just it really brought something
up inside of me
jealousy like i i want to be on that
cover
you know but really you could be there
too but dude but i i i don't think i
have any business being there right we
don't deserve to be on the cover yeah
but i never thought he did either
but but then but it does oh it's the
creator issue we're not even we're not
even we're not even in the conversation
and so here's so it's like yeah i'm
jealous i agree there's mr beast deserve
to be on the cover it's not about mr
beast this is about me
well
okay
and if jimmy if you think it's about you
call me you still have my number
and and if i keep this up i'm gonna have
to call you and pre-apologize yeah i'm
trying to cut you off so you can quit
digging your own thought about calling
him and saying you know what
congratulations or at least
congratulations on being on the cover on
so on but i was i was too jealous to do
it
so he definitely deserves to be on the
cover of rolling stone we do not i can
unequivocally say that
he might deserve to be on the cover of
wired or something where they like for
rolling stone all of a sudden have a
creator issue is reaching anyway if
they're doing a creator issue then he
deserves to be on the cover yeah yeah
yeah swimming that's what i'm saying
but
we deserved
to be in the creator issue i think that
we're just we're boring we're boring to
people like rolling stone well yeah
we're not we're not
i mean we got to do something about this
boring success you know we don't have
that flashy swimming and money success
it's like
i mean we did something wrong man we
should have been we should have been
giving away money for years
and making a making a big viral
hoo-hoo about do you want my honest
opinion on this or do you or do you want
me to go along with the bit that you're
doing
my i'm hot
you think this is a bit i know you don't
actually feel as strongly as you're as
you're acting right now
i
okay
i mean
because i don't know man because you and
i both know that yes i mean first of all
no one is getting excited about i mean
i'm not saying that we're the victims of
ageism but no one's getting it excited
about a 44 year old and 44 45 soon to be
45 and 44 year old dudes
like who make youtube videos and been
doing it for as long as we have
he is much flashier and more exciting
and his uh i mean just look at the
traction that he gets on an individual
video
you know it's mind-blowing yeah and yeah
it's like i wish we could come up with
an idea that would that would do that at
this point in our career but i wouldn't
trade our career to do it i'm very proud
of what we've accomplished in terms of
like the longevity of our career and the
trajectory of our career but i
acknowledge that it's not the kind of
thing that should get you on the cover
of rolling stone because it's kind of a
boring story it would be like
these guys on the cover of rolling stone
have a very successful digital media
company that has been
steadily growing
for a decade
who cares in terms of hold on let's say
let's say at least 15 years yeah but i'm
saying in terms of
uh from the rolling stone level person
on the cover of rolling stone you got to
be somebody that's
like this is sensational like he by
definition is a sensational like
everything that he does is sensational
and so
name the person that's been on the cover
of rolling stone who wasn't doing
sensational things yeah yeah yeah yeah
so my question is
i really want to be on the cover we are
not a sensation
period
and you know what that's that's been a
key to our success
unsensationally honestly i the moment
the article was sent to me
and it was like hey to break it to you
but mr beast is on the cover i read that
thing and the reason why i read it was
to make myself feel better about it not
being us it's like what about what about
this piece on mr beast can make me feel
better about not being
as sensational as him
and i'm i'm not going to say
how i reacted to certain parts of it but
yeah it's kind of like when i listen to
john mayer sing and he's talking about
how ollie he just he wishes he had a
wife and kids and i'm like okay yeah
that's good for me to hear
because i got that i got something at
your age that you don't have right and
he doesn't have anything that we want
uh
he has a full sleeve and it's like
i would like to have a full sleeve he's
on my list
so oh okay he's not he's actually we'll
get to that he's actually not on my list
but i'm not i'm not done talking about
mr b so i got another 10 minutes of
jealousy that i just need to work out
you should do that on uh like your side
your side probably my side piece yeah
um i can move on
so yeah you know what i'm gonna i'm
adding mr beast to my list because i
wasn't thinking about any digital
creators it's like i you know i started
thinking about categories and i didn't
think about that but yeah i am also
jealous of them
um you didn't think about digital
creators interesting no okay that's
again i and i think this is i think
actually this uh
the fact that i didn't think about
digital creators
is an indication of the way that i think
about jealousy and the way i think about
the aspects of the people on my list
that i aspire to is it's things that i
want i'm like i've got the digital
creator thing going yeah i'm not on the
cover of
rolling stone yeah but i wasn't thinking
in that category at all
you know what we should do though
and i was to move on i was telling
christy this i think you're going to be
into this i just want to go ahead and
put it out there i'm going to pitch this
to you all right i've kind of soft
pitched this but you i don't think you
understood that i meant it
we could be sensational and i have the
way to do it
oh no no no i don't want to no no no no
no no yeah and this is this is a
horrible idea you might get naked
i want us to pose nude
yeah you can do magazine yeah you can do
that
okay fine it feels it feels desperate
it depends on how it looks
i mean flula was on the cover of hustler
flula was on the cover of hustler
i would and he looked great and he
didn't look desperate trust me i would
box you nothing about that he looked
desperate to me i i would uh tell us
more i would uh box you before i would
get naked i didn't get to see the inside
of the magazine because i didn't show is
if that's what you're asking i didn't
yeah great i don't want to show my wang
either
perfect
okay well i'm not prepared to do that oh
no we'll we'll have to train for it
i think it'll be a great way for us
personally to like to really turn a
corner i'll get naked with you in a
magazine because i'll have to train in
order to be ready but if i'm going to
train i'm also going to fight you in a
boxing ring
no i'm not going to no because i want to
look pretty i want to look i want to
look you we'll take the photos before i
beat the
hell out of you
[Laughter]
it's all on the same day the morning is
the photo shoot and the night is the
boxing match dude i
i don't even know what is this freaking
like
matt watson got the crap beat out of him
by
uh
what's his nathan barnett nathan
freaking barnett
they call him dad now like we just know
nathan because we used to
we made videos back in the day uh with
him
and uh
and first of all i don't know anything
about the event like no one invited us
oh well
but now that we're talking about it
sensational enough yeah yeah but here's
the thing maybe they think we're above
it we're not above anything i'm taking
it all back i'm this is for me this is
all a bit i'm not going to box you i'm
not going to get naked because i just
think i think it's a sign of desperation
and i don't i'm i i'm not i'm not i'm
not saying i'll get i won't get there at
some point but i'm not ready i just
think it would be fun
like christy
uh didn't love the idea but but i'm
going to wear her down
lando
he he hated the idea
i so i think it's really like i think
men lando might need to be uh he might
need to graduate from high school before
this happens
like the last kid needs to be out of the
house but you're just making it tougher
and tougher on yourself right which
makes it more sensational
yeah
okay well we can consider it when lando
graduates from high school uh we'll talk
about it again
what's your number 10 um
john morant
don't know the guy
girl i don't know what
what
john marant ja
ja morant what is that
what is that who is that it's a better
question
um he's a nba basketball player for the
memphis grizzlies and he's like what i
so
i picked an athlete and this is my
number 10
because
whenever i watch professional sports
though i am jealous of the way that
these guys can
move their bodies and accomplish things
physically that
i would
i would you know my body would break in
the process of doing it and so just like
you i mean if you know you know you know
what i'm saying so now i'm not talking
to link i'm talking to you
to watch this guy play basketball and do
and just like a bathroom break
to see him
like you know i was like i'm gonna pick
somebody from the nba who's it gonna be
and then the most exciting
physically impressive like in terms of
what he can absolutely like he he's he's
like six three
but like just flies over people and does
all this stuff and he's young he's like
only been in the league like two years
so it's like i'm yo i'm gonna pick
lebron but no lebron's like so is it old
no so it's it's more of like the the
athleticism than being a basketball
player you're not jealous of being an
nba player you're no no
i'll take being an nba player as well
it's not necessarily a lifestyle that i
aspire to it the the thing that i am
the the specific thing that i'm jealous
of is just his ability to basically make
it look like he's doing magic you know
what i'm saying so you got somebody like
steph curry but the way that this hits
home i think the way that it's real that
it really is is true jealousy
is
like you're feeling the limitations of
your own body and i and i you know i
love to compete and i love sports okay
and i i love playing sports but this is
real i can't even play i can't play
pickup basketball anymore because it's
like uh i might hurt my back or my
shoulder's a little bit messed up you
know what i'm saying so wow there's real
pain here i'm sorry so and so instead of
picking somebody like steph curry who's
obviously super exciting to watch but
like steph just goes up and like lays it
in yeah like john morant is doing steph
curry type things but then he just keeps
going to the basket and then
jumps over somebody and dunks it and
like i would just love to see what that
feels like i think there's any amount of
training that you could do with the hope
that physical therapy has given you with
your shoulder that you could be able to
play pickup basketball again
not like john morant i know but
i could be like this but isn't there a
way that you could at least play pickup
basketball i mean
but it wouldn't be fun my papa's bro
that would be like bracing the whole
time played in a senior citizen
basketball league and they were like in
back in north carolina they were state
champions he was a senior citizen state
champion basketball player
he like traveled the state playing
basketball i'm not interested in that
okay all right fine uh if i'm going to
compete i want to compete at the highest
level not at the y
okay no i no i would be in to pick up
basketball and i would be maybe doing it
if if i if i wouldn't have to be like
when you have to play in a compromised
state and you're and you're basically
like you know i would be good you guys
don't know how good i would be i would
actually be contributing but now i'm
just kind of standing there with my with
my
my stomach flexed to protect my back
just say you're posting up yeah right
see if you know you know
i know
and now i know who that guy is check out
sport they have rankings that tell you
what to get at the grocery store do you
go to the grocery store
do you want to know what i mean
do you need something to make going
shopping at the grocery store more
exciting
well go to sport and they can give you
accurate they can give you some things
to get excited about that you can try
because they've tried it all and they're
adding stuff constantly to the site i
don't know how many items get added in a
week or a day but
literally they're constantly tasting
stuff whenever i see one of the sports
people in the office i'm like what
you've been tasting a day and then be
like well i just tried 25 mayonnaises
and uh it's a beautiful thing i'm moving
on to graham crackers you know it's like
it blows my mind that people can be
critical of sport because it is a
freaking service
i mean
it's a freaking service
and
there's you know there's there's fun
personalities that are contributing to
it um
you know but
you're going to be critical of it
touched a nerve i mean i don't care
about you i don't he's critical of it
some fans are like you feel like
everything you put out you need to be
critical of it
it's a tool that tells you based on a
group of people that we trust including
us that say this is what you should buy
at the grocery store
you find a way to complain about it it's
like having somebody out in front of the
grocery store it's like hey here's a
list of the best stuff in the grocery
store and you're like well yeah i don't
like your list
spork.com i don't like your font
all right here is my number nine i'm
jealous of lil yachty oh yes lil yachty
hip-hop artist extraordinaire
i met the guy lincoln and i met him at
the video game awards thing
uh you were there you were not there you
were there i met him you were there yeah
you met him too
i didn't understand i didn't know who he
was i wish i understood more about
like
he's a rapper what an entertaining
person he is just even apart from his
music career
uh he's adventurous like lil yachty he
signs up for his adventures cool stuff
and all of that is inspiring the things
on the internet that he shows up on lil
yachty come on good mythical morning
let's do this
all that's inspiring but that doesn't
make me
thing that makes me jealous is that
he's onto reese's puff cereal
there's a freaking
lil yachty collab with reese's pieces in
front of it
he's it's it's it's a special box have
you got it uh lincoln has it yeah
i'm freaking jealous of it you gotta
hold on to that kind of thing like i
wanna i wanna he he he he he has it
displayed in his room oh good good uh
unopened i go in there sometimes at like
two in the morning
thinking if we're out of cereal i'm
gonna eat that reese's puff cereal that
he hasn't shut the box carefully and i
go in there and lincoln's still awake
it's like i keep staying up later and
later hoping that like he'll go to sleep
so that i can eat that reese's puff
cereal and no matter how late i stay up
he's always up later because he knows
that i'm after that cereal
i just feel like
i feel like we
should be on a cereal box we should have
we should be on a cereal man
it's like yeah i agree with this it's
like if a little yeah lily artis
deserves it
but don't i mean we have we have a more
we have a morning show
people eat cereal and watch us i think
it's tougher to get two people on a box
why one of us has got to take the front
one of us because it's not on it at all
it's just a collab that is his chest
it's not
it's uh it says a little yachty on it
but it does it doesn't show his face on
the front what i'm picturing him with
it's not like a spoon that would be
awesome yeah i don't know why they
didn't do that but like even that so
it's at a level that i feel like we
could do
we gonna have to make our own cereal in
order to get on the box yeah i'm sure
they could be arranged
yeah
yeah like back in 2008 we made our own
freaking shoe
just so we could
collab on a shoe
shout out to tweek
okay what's your number nine um
see i'm just tapping into the anger like
yes i'm playing it up i find it
interesting but i'm i find your angle
interesting but no it's i wasn't jealous
i wasn't expecting the anger
well i'm just wondering if you're going
in more of an inspirational direction
like you're not really tapping into the
hurt of a jealous take this number nine
jason momoa
okay
okay yeah there you go i mean i should
have put him higher maybe
yeah why is he number nine uh well just
because there's a lot of people that i'm
jealous of
uh and because the thing that i am
jealous of jason mamoa about is
very superficial
it's the way he looks
period like now first of all he's lived
an exciting life
uh he gets to he's got a cool job being
an actor he's he's always doing stuff
that seems like he's living an
adventurous and fun life he's into cool
stuff
so i guess i'm jealous of that but
the thing that i think about when i
think about him is the fact that
um
even you know when i roast myself like
in our tick tock where we we went into
the
board room and found the other rhett and
link who worked here with us yeah and i
called myself a bargain bin jason momoa
yeah um
[Music]
and then even when
you know i started growing out my hair
um
and you know jesse obviously had a crush
on jason mamoa and she's been vocal
about that and that's fine i mean that's
of course right i'm not surprised
but then when you start making a
decision my decision to grow up my hair
wasn't to look more like jason mamoa it
was for all the reasons that i've
explained but then once you realize that
that's what's happening in effect
then you start realizing how
there's just things about jason mamoa
that you will never
actually achieve
physically i mean obviously he has a jaw
a lower jaw which is helpful i don't
have one of those necessarily i mean i
could probably stick my head into a
smaller hole to get something out than
he can
okay if like if if it comes to that the
old head through the whole retrieval if
somebody's gotta force their head into a
small culvert to like extract a baby
with their mouth or something like that
then yeah probably gonna call on me
instead of mama no i think they would
just use their hand
no and everybody's hands are not
functioning in this particular universe
but then when um we were talking to
kimmy our
you know who styles us for our our
public appearances on like fallon and
such
yeah and then i find myself
like you know i'm i guess i'm sort of
kind of doing like more of a mamoa thing
and then she brings back yeah you gotta
you have to say that out loud and then
she and then she brings back
her interpretation of well this is kind
of a this is like so what i wore on
fallon is the most momoa that i have
been in public right
um
and you just start realizing that you're
on this
just like mr bryant used to say
i've never seen an asymptote touch it
i've never seen it i've never seen a
function touch his ass i've never seen a
function touch his ass that's our
physics teacher and
and matthew high school uh and so i feel
like
i am on a an asymptotic function
uh
trying to achieve jason mamoa ishness
but never being capable of it so it's a
you know it's a little bit of a imply
that you get really close though
i yeah i i mean it might be when you're
both 80.
that's true
yeah and you know okay so
i i've now i've heard from a second
person right okay
a second person so uh
some of our close friends uh
their daughter is an actor
uh who is gonna be in a was in a movie
with him that i don't know when it's
coming out but like they got to know him
fairly well right yeah
um and so
he has been shown
my photo shoot that you did for me of me
dressed up like him and then also my
halloween costume of me dressed up like
him yeah and so to the point now now
i've never met jason
we were going to be on fallon at the
same time but it didn't end up working
out
um
but i've been told that the last time
that our friend was was with him on set
and somebody he was talking to somebody
else he turned to her and said hey um
show him your friend that dresses up
like me
[Laughter]
oh yes and so
and then i was at a party the other
night dresses up like yeah that's that
that that's who i am to him
your friend who dresses up like me
you're becoming that to me too yeah yeah
and so
uh a friend who dresses i was at a party
the other night i was at a birthday
party the other night uh
that you were also invited to but you
couldn't go cause you were out of town
and i was talking to
my friend at this party
and he
has another connection to mamoa
and said it was he's like good friends
with
a guy that was directing or working with
jason
and so
he saw what i had done on instagram and
he and he sends it to his friend and
he's like hey send this to jason this is
my friend and then the guy was like he's
already seen it
he's already seen it basically because
he had told the director there's look at
this guy who dresses up like me i i
don't know he's going around she tells
the impression is that he's going around
telling people that there's a guy that
dresses up like him
and i'm that guy so he should be jealous
of me that's like jim morrison in hiding
saying look at this band that covers all
of our songs you know it's like it's
just a weird thing it's just a weird
thing uh shall we move on yeah
you know i don't need to rub your nose
in it you're already uh
i've done that you've already done that
um
my number eight is
it's kind of a toss-up i'm gonna put
these two together okay because i was
gonna put
uh a street sweeper and i'm talking
about the occupation okay like it's like
the you see these zamboni machines that
go down uh residential streets
and city streets yeah it's called
streets i'm familiar with the street
sweeper it's like an awesome machine now
growing up we didn't know about this
didn't know about it so maybe if you
live out in the country you don't know
about it i i was walking jasper this
morning and we had an encounter with one
of them and i was like this is going on
my list man i would i wish i'm jealous
of that pilot of that thing i wish i was
piloting a street zamboni right now
i didn't see
his or her face at all because the
street sweeper was going the other
direction but like there's so much power
under like you're sitting on so much
power and you're cleaning things and
there's a route
and you're alone
you can listen to whatever you want and
then i realize the reason why i'm
jealous of this person is really because
i'm jealous of people with big nice
yards
i'm i wanna i i just remember back from
my
summer job days of mowing grass like i
miss mowing grass i'm jealous of people
who get to mow their grass one day i
want to go back to mowing grass and i
want to like get the nicest lawnmower on
that on it that exists like there's some
of these lawnmowers that like like those
big industrial ones that like you can
you can turn on a dime
man i'm so jealous of those people i i
don't want to hurt i don't want to hurt
this dream but i'm just telling you that
grass has really fallen out of fashion
you know it's just it it's
it's not here i wouldn't do it here
yeah in the drought-stricken region yeah
so you're gonna have to you're gonna
have to move you got to move to the
south
now i'm just gonna buy a big yard
or maybe just rent someone's yard fly
there
where there's like you buy a field in
north carolina and just go to there just
go and mow it i don't want it to be a
field though i like to have obstacles
and i like to have things to look at we
can install obstacles it's like tapping
into my childhood
really what we're talking about
maybe it's a
i would i'm using this term loosely it's
a garden not with other plants that need
to be maintained because you don't sound
like you're into that but maybe there's
sculptures
there's things that you have to i want
to i want to ride a big thing
no no no
you're on a big thing oh yeah on grass
but you said you wanted obstacles i'm
saying we could put fountains
sculptures and so we basically we've
created a garden
like a sculpture garden or maybe you
know what i think we just created a
graveyard
i think i yeah i could do that we just
reverse engineered a graveyard you need
to find a graveyard
in north carolina that maybe once a year
you can cut
i'm sure that can be arranged cause i'll
yeah yeah yeah so but you got there from
street sweeper because it's the same
thing i'm jealous of both of those
occupations and
when i'm driving down the interstate and
i see there's like mower ahead signs i'm
like oh yeah here we go contain yourself
boy
and then i look over there and they're
like it's a tractor that's mowing and
then there's this thing that comes down
on the side
the extension arm it's like i would just
love to be able to mow down a
embankment with that extension well you
know some things are easier to organize
than others and i think mowing is one of
the easier things to
organize until then i'll just be jealous
um okay i'm gonna my my number eight is
mauro morandi i'm probably not saying
that right let me talk about
uh well they're all gonna be people just
so you know okay who is that
murandi so i'm going to read about mauro
this is an inventor
no
okay an architect
uh no
okay
this is what he looks like an old dude
with a white beard and the biggest bags
under his eyes okay
i'm gonna i'm reading from a cnn article
uh
by sylvia
marchetti okay from 2021.
for nearly 33 years he lived a hermit
life on a beautiful island in the
mediterranean where he was the sole
inhabitant so the thing i am jealous
about
is the fact that he got to
live alone for an extended period of
time okay i've always had this yeah idea
of like i would enjoy a hermit lifestyle
mm-hmm so obviously not practical at
this point i have established a family
that i'm not going to abandon
um do you know what the grass is like on
the island i
i don't know
um
so this this is i want to tell you the
rest of the story because it's kind of
fascinating maro morandi known as
italy's robinson caruso
after developing a loyal online
following was caretaker of the sardinian
island of budeli
embracing silent solitude and the
peacefulness of nature while living in
an old beach stone hut there was no
social buzz no fancy food no friends his
only companions were birds and cats i
might change that to dogs but he slept
birds and dogs he slept on a cot and had
a few clothes forsaking all comforts he
preached a monastic existence of
self-reflection and meditation on
bodelli's pink beach dotted with coral
dust
so he you can read more about his
existence for 30 something years on this
island and also how how he ended up he
ended up there like apparently there was
like
i think he crashed there originally and
then he just ended up staying there but
then the people who the marine park
authorities
who basically
they wanted to evict him to turn the
isle into an environmental observatory
so
after years of them trying to get him to
leave he finally left
uh after posting a pithy message of
resignation
my balls are broken that's what he said
poor guy which is slang for i'm fed up
so
he was 82
when he moved
off of the island oh poor guy he's been
there 30 years yeah but it says moving
home and starting a new life can be
tough for anyone even more so for an 82
year old who has spent three decades
living a solitary existence on a
paradise island
is it possible to move on and readjust i
am not jealous of this guy at this point
says mirandi the answer is an emphatic
yes
once once i get to the end you'll see
why i'm jealous
it's never really over morondy tells cnn
i'm the living proof that a second nude
life is possible you can always start
over all all over again even if you're
over 80 because there are other things
you can experience a totally different
world proving his point morandi has
apparently been thriving since moving
back to civilization on the inhabited
island of la mad darlina not too far
from bedelli
la madalina i'm happy
and i have discovered the pleasure of
living the good life and enjoying
everyday comforts using his pension from
his former life as a teacher he's bought
himself an apartment with all the
luxuries he lacked before he's been
sharpening his skills as a communicator
after years of solitude he's now eager
to talk to people exchange views and
post photos and comments on social
networks to interact with the world he's
also been writing his memoir so he is
using social media in a healthy way
that's not possible so okay the thing i
love about this guy is he had the hermit
lifestyle
uh for 30 years yeah right balls got
broken balls got broken and he's moved
back to civilization and he's like
enjoying he goes on to talk about like
what enjoying a bed
and enjoying a kitchen
and
enjoying people and so like he's going
into his old age like living a second
life so
i'm jealous of this guy for two reasons
the hermit thing but also the fact that
most people when they get into their 80s
they're not beginning something new
right they kind of you feel like you're
in the sunset of your life but he's like
starting something new and experiencing
a whole new perspective on life and i'm
like
i'm not i don't think i'm going to be
able to arrange
a long-term hermit situation and i also
think that it's something that appeals
to me but i would get very bored very
quickly so
it's probably not going to happen the
best i'm going to be able to do is hey a
week-long solo trip
um
but
uh i think this guy's living his best
life and i'm jealous of him i'm gonna
put my number eight
is related to this one so i'm moving
this around i'm jealous every time i see
him and interact with him
park rangers
if and there's like a similar thing like
i don't want to be a hermit i don't want
to be alone but like
if you go to like a beautiful park like
think about going to yosemite and you're
interacting with these park rangers now
you can get on like a a crappy park and
you gotta i think you gotta work your
way up to the nice ones like
zion or something yeah i know some folks
who got um some mythical beasts who got
placed at uh the salton sea
but
i mean there's something to it i so i
found myself being jealous of those
people but then i think that's like
there's probably a big downside like you
just can't go wherever you want to go
you got duties you're a caretaker of the
forest you're like an ant like a human
ant i like that idea i'm jealous that
like i don't have an
so much of a connection with nature that
like there's a certain swath
of nature that i've spent so much time
in that i'm attuned to
every little change associated with it
so i'm jealous of that connection that
someone like a park ranger has with a
swath of nature
and maybe this is akin to the lawn
mowing thing too you know all the grass
is thicker because this time you can't
mow in a national park
there are certain places where i've seen
weed eaters in the national park but not
in the native grasses
you can't be cutting the natives
yeah you're right
you're right but then i'm like maybe i'm
just jealous of one of those hikers that
does the
appalachian trail
yeah like having the time to do that so
that's i i'm trying to settle on where
my jealousy really lies and i don't
think it's i think it's less of an
occupation and more of a
connection
with nature well i think that the hiking
the appalachian trail
i mean
just i still feel like we should do it
just
just
i mean it takes a long time no i'm not
necessarily the whole thing it's not i
mean you're talking about isolation it's
like that could be an insult to uh
you know the the loved ones you live
with oh they understand but it's like oh
you okay so you're so jealous that you
can't you can't get away from me can't
get away from us
but i but there is something
i was gonna say sexy but there's nothing
sexy about it there's something
intriguing about it adventurous i mean
i've always had this this uh
the secret
dream to do something like okay yeah
i am gonna hike the appalachian trail
this this year or the sailboat of it all
it's something that
yeah but it's just it's not
it's none of that is practical at this
point not just because
of relationships relationships but just
position in life it's like okay we can't
yeah do that if we're going to do
something like that we have to be like
well we're going to make it look like we
hiked the appalachian trailer we're
going to shoot it in a week and it's
going to be a youtube video you know
it's like
so but we should we should
do
um
i mean
i think we should set a date in a second
in the future
and it should be like by this time you
have to have made plans to do something
like that whether we do it together or
because i just think that before you get
too old you can't do something
adventurous like a lot of people do this
shorter
they they hike that trail in the uh
is it the one that goes from it's in
spain
and it like goes
i don't know to a bunch of like
oh i know what you're talking about
churches or something it's like a it's a
famous quest that people go on i mean it
does remind me that we do need to get
like
solo trips on the on the books again
that's gotta happen i keep trying to
find that time uh my number seven is not
uh unrelated to what we're talking about
because it's jared diamond so the jared
diamond is
he wrote one of my favorite books guns
germs and steel right so he's basically
he's also old you know he's 84. i'm just
jealous of i'm not jealous of
i don't want to be 84 right now
but i'm just jealous of how he got from
where he's at now you know from where he
was to how he got to
to 84 and what he's done in between
so this guy has written like the third
chimpanzee guns germs and steel
collapse the world until yet until
yesterday these
um
sort of
uh they're historical
scientific explorations of really
interesting things but
so he's i mean obviously he's like a
professor at the same time but he's just
a guy who has traveled the world and
been on places like easter island or new
guinea
you know he's a bird watcher which
that's not something that i necessarily
aspire to but like his bird watching
and his
his uh interest in
uh
is it ornithology is that what you call
it
took him to like he would take trips to
new guinea to like
discover and
observe birds so just somebody who's
sort of like as close to
a modern-day indiana jones is kind of
what i'm trying to find
writer
yeah so it's like traveling in order to
then
like find something out that you can
write about that a lot of people will
read and be like man this guy really put
it all together
the
the travel and the adventure
mixed with the knowledge that you're
getting and then the synth the synthetic
synthesizing of the knowledge into like
a work
like all those things are super
intriguing to me and so yeah you know
and so and you know and this
i could at this point in my life i can
be like well i can also travel
i can also watch birds
but i'm not i'm not trained you know
it's like i know i'm what if i'm going
to write a book it's it's not going to
be it's going to be like
the book of mythicality
you wouldn't write germs guns and steel
i think it would be fiction but it would
still be travel related you when you
need to justify a lot of research
i think that could be like your
your your swan song
well and i think that there's
there's something to
you know you look at what he's done a
bunch of stuff and he's obviously stayed
really busy but then it'd be like this
particular quest
resulted in this particular book and
it's like how many years of
thinking about because collapse is
really really cool the 2005 book that
uses the story of easter island and how
easter island basically decimated their
own population and their natural
resources because of an ideology that
they were following and with putting the
statues up and he uses that as an
analogy to talk about
what we're doing as a culture with our
commitment to you know consumerism and
you know the and what the results of the
impact on the environment will be
and so we're on a larger scale we're
doing what they did but it's like how
much how much
i want to go to easter island but i
don't want to go he doesn't go to easter
island
with like a cool backpack he got off of
instagram so he can take pictures that
he puts on instagram and that's the end
of it which is what i would probably do
right yeah like i took my film camera to
easter island i got some cool ass film
pictures of these statues here's my
carousel on instagram isn't this cool oh
man you've got an eye for photography
and that's the end of it right yeah
it's like no no
this guy goes there and he's like coming
to conclusions about things and like
making statements about things and
actually impacting the way that we're
moving forward as a civilization he's
not just trying to get likes on
instagram you know what i mean
i don't but i know that you do i'm yeah
i'm jealous
he's not going on my list but i i get
that i think that's totally you now this
is one that i think you're
we've talked about
that if it's not on your list
you're gonna put it on there because
we've had this discussion about being
jealous
of this duo
the coen brothers okay we talked
specifically about first of all they're
filmmakers they have built their brand
their identity on their amazing films
that they just say you know what it and
then we say things like man they just
they conceptualize this film and then
they just they get in a room and they
like beat it out and then they're like
there's a couch in there and they just
they'll leave it some days they'll just
like
sleep on the couch
and then wake up and keep writing and
storyboarding meticulously planning
everything that everybody
gives them
full trust and creative freedom to just
do their thing
and then every few years or so another
one comes out yeah and so
that creative experience especially in
the world of film that
was
always this aspiration of ours that we
have not achieved is something that
manifests as
jealousy when you hear about their
process
yeah and i have somebody on my list
later who
uh for the same exact reasons okay
um
but i think
the film part of it like i'm jealous of
that too it's like oh you know
conceptualizing oh yeah that's my world
yeah i think that there is um
you know
it's funny we had that conversation with
matthew mcconaughey
on this show i remember that and yeah we
kind of went into
getting his advice which he likes to
give advice that's kind of what green
lights is all about
um
and then we were basically talking about
our desire to create like we feel like
we're being held back and then he said
something like you don't need to ask for
permission and
and it's like yeah i
i understand that
um
but unfortunately we still kind of are
in a place where there is a certain
level of permission that we have to
receive right
you know you you think about what when
you want to create things on a certain
level
sure we can do whatever we want to on
the internet within reason if we can get
if we can mobilize our team to do it
yeah uh but it has to be
very
economical in order for us to be able to
pull it off both in time and in money
and so i think the thing that you're
tapping into is
somebody's like hey here's
plenty of money
to do something where we're not going to
come back necessarily and say you can't
do that because of money
you know i'm not saying they get to do
whatever they want to
they're not spending like
500 million dollars on their movies or
whatever they're still making movies
that are reasonable but like
no one is coming along even what we did
we did with inside eats right
proud of the show that we created but
we're creating it for
another audience in a lot of ways we're
creating it for it's got to work on food
network
right whereas they're just like i'm
making a movie that's just going to work
for anyone who wants to see the movie
that we're making and
no there's no we're not getting
permission from any for anybody
creatively yeah and you think about the
the buy-in they get any talent they want
like yeah is like clamoring to work with
them it's automatic yes give me your
next one number six john mayer i wanted
to put a musician on the list okay and i
and
i'm sure i could have you know i don't
he's not like the end-all be-all i'm
jealous of him in particular more so
than anybody else but i think that
there's a
um like i didn't put harry styles on
here right because i'm actually not
jealous the thing about a guy like harry
styles is somebody who is
defining culture like if he wears
something it's cool it doesn't matter
what he does
it's cool it's defining culture
and john mayer's not like that because
he's our age and he's not making pop
music anymore but the way that he's just
kind of doing what he wants to do
musically
yeah and also
the fact that his sole focus this is
another thing about each person on this
list
for me one of the things i'm jealous of
is people who have a focus
we don't have a focus we do we have like
12 jobs
right
but everybody on this list they do this
one thing really really really well
that's why
john mayer can play the guitar like a
complete badass because john mayer has
been playing the guitar
since he was a teenager in his bedroom
for hours and hours and hours on end
and
my relationship with the guitar is when
i have a song to write or something to
figure out i will play the guitar but
then weeks will pass when i don't pick
it up right because there's too many
other things going on
um so i think that somebody who is like
achieve something
really
admirable musically like is operating at
a very very high level musically but
also just making the music that they
want to make
so that's a specific idea i'm not
jealous of the fact that
john mayer has dated you know katy perry
taylor swift
fill in the blank jennifer aniston
jennifer aniston uh let's yeah let's not
let's not i have a policy of not
bringing up his dating life in in in as
part of my fandom of john mayer
period
yeah like you said he's not he's singing
songs about wishing that he was with his
old high school girlfriend
you know yeah naming their third baby
yeah right i i have a musician on my
list for totally different reasons okay
um
flea i'm jealous of flea the basis for
the red hot chili peppers
he he's i mean how old is flea okay give
me i'd say 58.
dude
give us a google
oh you're not listening to our show
how old how old is flea
the reason why i'm jealous of flea is
because
he's
he's 59 years old
and he's
the dude can move like i mean he's
second to mick jagger it's like this i
mean this mick jagger is like 30 years
older than i know but like to to make
that statement about the dude 20 years
older is is astonishing for me i guess
i'm i will be jealous of mick jagger one
day but i'm not now
i'm jealous of flee because
i never learn to play an instrument but
the way that he plays
yes i can i can
i can get by on some
instruments for comedic effect but i
never learned to play an instrument and
i chose him because
he channels so much of himself yes he's
he's an excellent
arguably the most famous one of the
rock bases one of the most famous
bassists period
i love the bass guitar i love what it
does for music
but the way that he channels his entire
body
into his music
and
just
feels it is something that i would i
just
with my connection to music the way that
it's
i just no i just wish i could have it
flow out of me like you could you see
him
do it and like i spared no expense for
my chili peppers
tickets when they come to l.a well you
know i think you can potentially
is is there any dj that also has a base
i'd have to learn the bass i'm not
prepared to learn the bass at this point
in my life
honestly well
but yeah i mean but you got a lot of
time left what i'm saying is but it's
not the thing cool yeah i'm to play the
bass as a d like you're doing the dj
thing i can't pursue the bass thing at
the same time but just the embodiment
and to have music flow through you in
that way that's like
second nature like you're not thinking
about what you're playing you're just
thinking about what you want to exude
and you're so good at it you've mastered
it to the point where oh but
that's just
i i'm jealous of that i'll never have
that feeling
well that's probably true
but i have it in other ways but what i'm
saying is i have experienced flow in a
way that's like i know enough of it to
want it to go through a base but think
about this if you're djing
and it's like all of a sudden
the song comes on here and and it's like
oh man that that sounds good but there's
no bass line in that song yeah when is
the bass going to drop and you think
that the bass is going to drop within
the song but then dj link or whatever
your dj name ends up being pulls out a
bass guitar yeah
you don't even have to actually play it
yeah because you can you can do a low
it looks like you're playing you could
take the bass out of anything that
you're playing and replace it with your
own bass line i'm just giving you ideas
it's a great idea for somebody maybe
i'll get there uh my number five goals
my number five is jeff goldblum
uh
okay for a whole bunch of reasons
but i will say that i think that jeff
goldblum
in his
advanced stage and i'm just saying
advanced age compared to us he's not
like about to die
but
being old
but achieving
iconic status where you can kind of say
anything that you want and people are
like jeff goldblum said that
or you know jeff gold jeff like if we
went to a party
and somebody said jeff goldblum's here
he would yeah what do you think about
that we'd be like well who doesn't like
jeff goldblum i know you know what i'm
saying
um so it's not so much what jeff
goldblum
was able to accomplish to become jeff
goldblum which would it be yeah being a
famous actor would be super fun
but that's not specifically what i'm
jealous of
it's
you can be oh look what jeff goldblum
has on
look at jeff goldblum in that commercial
that's about apartments
yeah but he just made apartments.com
cool because he's jeff goldblum all
right i'm he's on my list now and yeah
you're exactly right for me i'm just
jealous of
his vibe what he's done is he's given
himself over completely to his
eccentricities
and there are times talk about tapping
into flow that i feel like i can
uneventually give myself over to my
eccentricities and it feels good
but i don't live in that place i'm
jealous that it seems
that he lives in that place
but it isn't as simple as that
because
you know
he jeff goldblum isn't nothing against
you but most people can't give
themselves over to their eccentricities
you just you are you aren't it's not a
decision no no no well yeah to that but
most people can't give themselves over
to their eccentricities and still be
broadly appealing to pretty much
everybody do you know what i'm saying
like
he's he's a weird dude but
everyone
likes his li
is it is drawn to i don't anybody who's
like i hate jeff goldblum yeah you know
what i'm saying he's got a magnetism
like when jeff goldblum gets super weird
and crazy and does something it's like
it's always endearing it's never
annoying it's just like that's just so
hard for for people to do i it's a magic
it's sort of a magic
power
that
most people just don't have i don't i
don't i don't think there's a version of
me in the future that could achieve jeff
goldblum's status like it's not in my
dna makeup to be i think i could do it
yeah see that's what i'm that's where
i'm differing i'm having a difference of
opinion well
i don't need i don't need your opinion
because i think that it would appeal to
a lot of people but there's you would
not you leaning into your eccentricities
would not appeal to as many people as
jeff goldblum well i'm already an
acquired taste i'm not for everybody but
i've said that it's just it's yeah how
is he forever there's a phenomenon yeah
there's a phenomenon there's a few
people like that that this is like you
can't
hate on jeff goldblum
he behaves in a way
that you would think would be polarizing
but it's not it's kind of like a dolly
parton
it's a bit of dolly part it is it's a
there's a i mean but
in the magnetism and like yeah who can
hate on dolly parton but it's fertility
it's a totally different vibe i'd love
to see the two of them together because
i also don't get the impression that
jeff goldblum he's a pianist he's
working
as hard as a dolly parton no he's you
know what i'm saying like
working hard isn't that wasn't that like
nine to five i mean i'm saying i mean at
least nine to five all the time what do
we make a living i mean
95 to me sounds kind of like banker's
hours but uh
dolly's working way more than five to
five that's
yeah but i don't think goldblum is
like what's goldblum doing right now
probably relaxed something that i would
like to be with him for whatever it is
i'm game
uh
you know what you know
a person i'm jealous of it's a group of
people
um when i'm mountain biking
you know i got this one round i do it
takes me two hours i'm going up
up up only up
for an hour and 20 minutes
and then it you know like 30 minutes
back down
the same give or take the same route
um
but then
you get overtaken by a couple of people
and then you find yourself looking over
your shoulder because you don't want you
want to be that guy who's like you're
listening to something and then there's
somebody behind you forever and they're
like trying to get by you and like
judging how slow you're going so you get
a little i get a little self-conscious
you learn when you turn
a corner to like give a little look
just to make sure there's not somebody
back there
but then there's sometimes when it's
like people get so
they're in so much better shape
that they just like they'll just find a
way around even before i realize that
they're there because they're coming up
on me so fast and it's it's a bit
it's a bit soul-crushing
uh
and it's happening more and more
but the thing that i'm noticing is that
and i've learned to look and immediately
identify
these people it's like this guy's got 10
years on me
what the hell yeah he's on an e-bike
e-bikes are
are really taking over
e mountain bikes so they're they're wow
batteries are driven assistance to get
up the hill yes
and
you know a lot of people judge them for
it
um
you know i've learned to stop judging
myself because i know where to look on
the bike because they can't it's it's
the frame the frame has a bigger part
down there that's okay that's where the
motor is this guy's just trucking i mean
they go up so fast it it looks fun going
up like i'm jealous of these people
having fun for that hour and a half then
i'm just killing myself so that i can
experience the reward of getting up
there and the fun of coming down but
they're having the fun going up and the
fun coming down and they don't need a
helicopter from your friend planning
your perfect day so you're jealous of
them because they i'm jealous because i
just can't allow myself to go there but
i have decided i'm not going to judge or
hate on them anymore because
it's giving them access i mean they
wouldn't have the ability i don't think
you still have to do some work
no not really you yes you have to pedal
a little bit but let me tell you
they're not even breaking a sweat man
you know it's not it's you pedal
but no not really this explains why i
saw
when shepard and i were like hiking up a
mountain recently on a fire road oh gosh
and we saw trucking
uh well he was stopped he was stopped in
like drinking water
but he was old and i was like how the
hell is this guy getting up this
mountain he buys us to have an e-bike
yeah and um
there will come a day
when i will get one of those
but like i just can't allow myself to do
it now because it's my you know that's
that's what's keeping me in shape is not
allowing myself to get one of those
well and you know what you could but i'm
jealous that they're experiencing that
but they also probably you know you
don't have to use it the whole time if
you have like a standard yes but that
there's no way
like you're sitting there like trudging
in granny gear knowing that you could
just zip right on up the mountain
no that would never happen
it's funny that we're jealous of old
people like everybody on the list is old
people
yeah older than us give me another one
um
she is older
marina o'loughlin
no relation
uh
[Music]
before this exercise you did not know
these people yeah well like you use this
as an occasion to like come up with
people well let me say why
she's a food critic
okay and so
and she's number four on my list if it
gives you any idea of how important this
is to me
someone that you just googled on the
internet but food critic is really what
you're going for and the reason that i
did not know about her
well first of all it's not like i'm up
on the world of food critics
but also while she is a very
accomplished food critic she's known for
her anonymity
so she's not like when i started looking
i want to find a food critic on my list
because i've always loved the idea of
just being
someone who gets paid to eat which is
again yes i kind of do that already yeah
you do that already but
it's not the same i'm not eating in a
fine dining establishment and then
giving you my refined opinion on it well
don't let the mythical kitchen hear that
and also
um
she has not positioned herself as a
personality
because she kind of talks about the the
fact that
you know these people who if you look up
food critics most of them like oh and
they have this tv show and they have
this show that they're on or they're a
judge on this thing
she's kind of avoided that because she
wants to maintain her even though you
can you can find out what she looks like
and people do know who she is
uh
but
she's got anonymity when it comes to the
restaurants
but she has anonymity when it comes to
the public
which as a restaurant critic you
probably eat by yourself quite a bit
i've always been very resistant about
eating at a restaurant by myself
or going to a movie by myself because
movies easier i don't think i've ever
been to a restaurant alone but like you
know my wife went on a solo trip a
couple years ago and she just went to
restaurants by herself you know and
and
but i i'm self-conscious of it because
i'm like well i'm it's fine if you're
the way if like i just tell the waiter
i'm here alone but then there's this
part of me that's like yeah but if you
know who i am then it's like all right
just eats by himself because he can't he
doesn't have any friends so you're
jealous of being able to eat alone
without being judged for it well that's
one aspect of it but also if you just
look at the articles that she writes i
think she's with the times
now in in in
england
um
but she
doesn't just she'll go to like i'm
reviewing this hotel that has a
restaurant i'm reviewing the hotel and
the restaurant and this is like
posh hotel somewhere in wales and she's
like writing about it
so she gets to travel which travel to
travel to nice places to stay in nice
places to eat nice food
is a very appealing thing that i like to
enter i like to i like to do those
things but you like to redeem the travel
by writing i
i think you're on to something here you
want to travel
with a purpose of writing
second time has come up i think and you
want to eat there's there's definitely
something to
for me
when i experience something i'm
compelled to write about it because it
helps me to
understand it better for myself you know
what i'm saying like it's like when you
you have this experience like i'm going
to put this in my journal not so that
somebody can necessarily read it
but it helps me understand what happened
to me and understand remember like i you
know i had these i have this list on my
in my evernote which is like things i
like
and it's and i haven't added to it for a
long time but it's just like i want to
remember that this restaurant was good
or i don't remember that this
this place was a really fun place to go
there's something about cataloging that
that is important but also it's just the
lifestyle you know what you should do
you should commit yourself
to being a yelp writer
it that's a perfect journal it can be
anonymous
where you can have you i'm sure you can
look at your own
account and have a record of everywhere
you've eaten and just a little something
that you've said about it don't write it
don't do it for other people i mean
they'll benefit from it but maybe you'll
start to get noticed because of your
prose
i don't know anonymously
come on man think about it don't poo poo
it don't make the stink face this is a
good idea i think that i want to to
write in a more um
you want the cr you want this you want
the cred no no that's not what i mean
yeah i do want cred but that's not why
that's not what i'm jealous about but
you can still get it i mean people
people get cred from writing amazon
reviews
it's a different style
it's a different style though you could
be the first it's not experiential make
it experiential it's like we had
we had the hawaiian shrimp combo
no there there are more everyone at my
table ordered so
i don't there's a different no there are
people who write reviews in a different
way
you could do it your way you think
there's somebody who and you have a
record of everywhere that you've eaten
and it gives you it's like well i gotta
eat somewhere else because i gotta you
think that's somebody who wrote a yellow
they counted on me wrote yelp reviews
and then transitioned into full-time
food critic
is that what you want
no i'm just saying that i just don't
think that bridge gets there is that
what you want
no but i if i'm going to write the
reviews i want it to be
i want to be able to approach it as a
food critic not as just a yelper
it just feels like a distinctly
different exercise that's your only path
i mean you need a portfolio i think i'm
just going to keep eating at
good restaurants and maybe start eating
them alone
um
i only have what two more
i this one right here again it's another
older person i'm about i just gave you
my number four so i have three more oh
maybe i'm cutting ones
um
this guy's 49 years old
but he
ever since like for for decades he has
been a prolific
uh music producer
and i'm i this is this one's
much more squarely inspirational than it
is jealous i get i i actually don't know
exactly what i'm jealous of pharrell
about
but i think i can start to put my finger
on it
um
the dude
has you know for for decades has been
creating music producing music showing
up in all types of places
uh of course
with the neptunes back in the day but
then
i mean he he's
at at his age he's still
producing for
the top artist
on the planet
like uh
the new kendrick album he he produced uh
mr morale that's the only song he
produced on there
but to be on that album which is like
you know
it's like a
a treasure a time capsule it's like this
this artistic expression is something
that will always be referred to
not just in hip-hop
whether whether you go back and listen
to it all the time or not
that's it's just you can't deny it
the fact that like he's working with
kendrick he's working with
he's and he's like he's singing the hook
on uh
uh the pusha t
album
uh which i really like so it's like
and uh
he actually sang the hook on all right
the kendrick song from uh
to pimp a butterfly so like he's he's
he's been around he's in the mix and
he's like
he's getting older he first of all he he
doesn't he doesn't look funny he looks
like i mean he looks so young but he's
staying young like i again i think this
is more of an inspiration but the thing
that i'm jealous of is that like
he's in this he's in the world with
these musicians that are at the an
artist at the top of their game he's
like rubbing shoulders with him he's
creating with him so he's not just a fly
on the wall but he's like in the mix
and that's just like it's a world that's
so fascinating to me
and i just i love the idea of it so i'm
jealous that like this guy gets to walk
into a room and you know if prince were
alive he'd go he'd go up and talk to him
you know yeah he was in that uh
that kanye documentary
right like in the early days of kanye
like
yeah and there's like that scene where
he like recognizes he recognizes his
talent and he's it was like he just
there weren't no one was expecting it at
the time right
and he looked exactly the same as he
does now yeah it's just so weird yeah
he'd be a cool guy i have a music
producer in my top three but he's
already my number three so i'm going to
give you my number three what just do i
might order uh
okay well
i'll give you my number two then my
number two is rick rubin oh yeah um same
thing see i
i got you to watch that paul mccartney
thing because you told me
yeah the three two one and also even
though he doesn't actually
cameo in it in the second season of dave
um there's like the rick rubin episode
i don't remember that
wasn't that dude
fell off i didn't finish dave season two
for some reason
really i gotta finish that
um
i think that's the show that i saw it on
so what about
what about him makes you jealous
uh
well
he has simultaneously
um
achieved what you're talking about
pharrell being able to achieve in terms
of
being
very much
in the mix of
it's like on the cutting edge of culture
right yeah for a very long time
but at the same time
his
personal journey
of spirituality and into meditation and
also just physically what he looks like
he'd completely departed from the path
of like be i am trying to be cool in in
this way and i dress cool and i it's
like rick rubin wears like a t-shirt
and shorts and flip-flops everywhere he
goes and obviously does not do anything
to his hair or beard except just let it
grow
yeah and
he's a musical guru yeah and so yeah
he's well and i i think he's somewhat of
a spiritual guru right because he is
he's obviously got a high level of
equanimity in his life through his
practice of of meditation
um
which my understanding is that it's it's
very advanced and developed
so he's just a very calm and peaceful
guy who seems to be
he's gotten to a place where the things
that bring him pleasure
and
fulfillment and joy he's like he's he's
parsed out his life in his older age to
know like this is what i want to be
doing
and i'm going to focus exclusively on
these things that bring me joy
and everything else is going to just
fall to the wayside including like what
i look like
now obviously the net effect is
he looks like a badass because he
because he looks like he doesn't care
what he looks like so it you know so
he's got the and he's got this compound
in malibu
and then he's got another place in
hawaii and artists just show up for him
to work his magic yeah like he he's like
i've set up my life and now these people
are going to come to me
you know yeah so his proximity to these
artists sort of culture defining
things
that keeps you kind of young and keeps
you in the mix but yet being totally
separate from it at the same time that's
he's the only person that i know or he's
the best example of a person who's
achieved that being in the world but not
of the world you know to use a biblical
reference right
so he's very much in it he's completely
in it he but then he like lives like
what feels like a man his outward
appearance is like someone who's living
a monastic
lifestyle
um
yeah so i mean i i just the idea of
being you know 20 30 years from now
i don't know how he's not he's not that
much older than us but like
achieving that type of equanimity but
still being
involved in creating great art
that's that's i'm jealous of that i
don't know what equanimity means
i'm trying to infer that it just means
uh
basically a balance
like
balancing balance in your life people
enjoy
life equilibrium yeah okay
okay
it's basically what you're you're
supposed to say i don't know what
equilibrium means it's it's what you're
trying it's what you're trying to
achieve this ultimately whatever
whenever everybody says that they're
they're going after
joy
or happiness silent lucidity what
they're really talking about is
equanimity because
you can't be happy all the time like
that's not a state that you could just
be in you're going to have happiness
you're going to have sadness you're
going to have you're going to experience
the the gamut of human emotions but like
are you
constantly kind of coming back to the
center
are you balanced okay you have
equanimity yes yeah i do thank you
i didn't know what it meant but i
totally am nailing
that um
okay i guess i
so i took
i i'm taking my dogs off my list i was
jealous of my dogs but i'm taking them
off the list to put
whoever i put on the list because you
told me to oh yeah
but i guess i gotta keep on my list i'm
jealous of people who don't have to
sleep a lot
but
i'm more secure in being able to
magically nap anywhere at any time
as a superpower so it kind of balances
itself out i'd love to be able to have
both though like i'm a super sleeper and
a super napper but i also want to not
ever need it
i don't think those people really exist
though maybe they don't yeah i liked
hearing that i mean i don't know
they're fooling themselves a lot of
people depriving themselves and they'll
die young a lot of people have brought
into question uh i think i actually
wrecked it at one point that book about
sleep uh it turns out that
you're unwrecking the book now well it's
just been there's been a i don't know i
can't i don't know if i wrecked it and
so i can't unwreck it uh but if i did
wreck it i can say that there are
certain things that the guy says in the
book it isn't like it's all made up and
it's not true but there is some like
manipulation of the data in a way to
kind of like make his point but one of
the things that he talks about is that
those people who say that oh i only need
four hours of sleep but like
it's actually much more rare
than
probably not they're foolish it's like
probably not actually you probably would
be healthier if you were getting six to
eight hours of sleep by the way the
people who are literally full of [ __ ]
then they got a problem too it's like
you're not jealous of them no no no no
no i've been on a really good run lately
um
yeah so i don't know man so do you have
two left or one left two
okay so give me your two and i'll give
you my one
well how about i give you one then you
do one then i can get you i go last i
think we might have because i only have
one left i think we might know than the
same number one i only have one left
yeah so i'll do mine and then you do
yours and then i'll do mine exactly but
you said give me your two i thought you
wanted me to go two in a row no give me
your two i'll give you my one then you
give me your one
oh i thought you said give me your two
like i did say give me your note i
thought you're like give me your last
two that's what i'll heard you give me
both of your two so that i can wrap this
up yeah that's what that's what i
interpreted that as you said you were
saying give me your number but leave the
best in me man um i want you to so i
want you to have the grand finale my
number two is rick rubin
my number three is jordan peele for the
same reason you are he's an inspiration
he made that list well i'm because i'm
jealous of him
okay um
for
all kinds of reasons for all the reasons
that i talked about him being an
inspiration before the community
the coen brothers thing
in that he has gotten to a place where
uh he is exercising this creative
control over these film projects
and everyone is just like i can't wait
for the new jordan peel nope
you know still waiting uh i'm ready and
also
the fact that
there's a there's a a bit of a parallel
career and that he yeah
was a you know i'm not saying i want to
go and make movies by myself but i'm
saying the fact that he it was in this
comedic duo that you never expected
either of oh yeah it makes sense that
they might go on to be actors but to
become this master filmmaker he was
sitting on this incredible skill this
whole time
so the way that he has basically
reshaped any and all expectations about
him based on what he's done in the past
is something that
i'm like
almost 100 sure that that's not
something that is is going to occur in
my lifetime is is as much as i like to
achieve things and as much confidence as
i have
i understand the extreme unlikeliness of
like oh i'm going to fart out some
culture defining film that's you know
what i'm saying so it's just like
something that i'm always going to be
jealous of is the fact that he was able
to pull that off
that's
inspirational and jealousy inducing um
my number one i can't remember if you
put this on your inspirational list
this guy but i did not
um
mine my my ranking is kind of arbitrary
but i think this is a good one to end on
for me okay um i'm jealous of bo burnham
because
we came up together on the internet
you know
and
so it's like having this a very similar
starting point to for him to be in this
place where
you know he's
he's not beholden to the internet
in the way that we are and of course you
know when we saw him at that party and
he was like hadn't talked to him in so
many years and he was like
you know he's he was very nice and he
said
something to the effect of
you guys have
made made it work on the internet you've
made it work for you and like you're
you're still doing it i think he
actually said something like you guys
are a cultural institution
just i mean i cuz i i remember i
remember those and now i kind of he was
being
super he's super nice guy super
complimentary um
but there was a part of me that was like
yeah but like man it's i mean it's just
we both know that it's just a dumb
internet show where we eat things every
week we're not doing inside on netflix
i didn't hear yeah i didn't
my insecurity
told me that i did not hear him say
man i really i really respect you guys
in terms of your your community your
comedic sensitive
uh sensibility and comedic expression
like you know we have this thing where
we want
comedians that we respect to
to like the things that we create and
not just the
be mesmerized by the fact that we were
successful on a platform that they
didn't have the stomach for is how i
felt like i felt like that was what was
in his compliment was that like you know
i didn't want to keep playing the
youtube game
kudos to you guys for doing that
to to an extreme
um
i you know i just his artistic
expression in inside is uh
yeah
it makes me jealous because i feel like
not only do we have a very similar
starting point but we have similar
capabilities
and sensibilities
you know it's just similar in that they
kind of are geared in the same way but
not to the degree
just in my opinion yes
yeah okay
in other words we ain't as talented as
bo burnham
you know so by long shot but but we like
to do the same types of things yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it makes it salt in the
wound so to speak
i must have just blocked this one out
because he's definitely on my list
and and i would say that for all the
reasons that you just said now you have
to knock off your number one no i just
knock off so i get defensive i'll knock
off uh
the old guy who lived on the island
um he's off the island now
uh
i think one of the things that i'm
jealous of with vo burnham and also my
number one which i'll get to in a second
is the fact that
we have not only created like the
decisions that we've made
in our career in order to remain
relevant and successful and to build a
company
has involved
quite a bit of giving of ourselves not
just our time but literally
giving of ourselves
words that come out of our mouths and go
onto the internet like there's so much
that we're putting out there of
ourselves
on this podcast being vulnerable right
and
and
you know i
it was almost like when you take inside
bo burnham hasn't been saying anything
on social media he doesn't
say anything on twitter he doesn't he's
not constantly he doesn't have a podcast
he's not constantly talking about
himself and what he thinks right
but then he bottles all that up and puts
it into this hour-long special
that is like this is what i've been
thinking
these are my thoughts
not given to you in this steady stream
where you can't escape me by going on
the internet but like if you want to
tune into this fire hydrant of
expression and creativity and
vulnerability it's in this special that
i've been working on for this length of
time and now i'm working on this other
thing and you know what you'll be around
for and i don't have to stay in your on
your radar with every little piece of
content that i put out i'm jealous of
that i'm jealous that somebody can be so
prolific
yet
not have some so much volume
in their output
before you give
your number one
uh
do you think that this has been a
uh a positive experience for us to have
this discussion
like i was more worked up at the
beginning
your your brows a little crinkled at
this point do you feel like this we're
getting things out there and that it's
cathartic or that it's fomenting
something
um
i think those are the same
so i i think that if you have a if you
have a frustration
um by taking it out looking at it and
expressing i mean this is what i do in
therapy right i'm assuming this is what
you do in therapy as well if there's
something that is on your mind in this
way
i think that it is only good to
vocalize it and actually examine it so
ultimately yes very positive
but it may not be like oh this is going
to put me in a good mood right now but
that's not how i'm going to judge
whether or not there's a net positive
you know
you you know me i get very creatively
frustrated right because of
i'm extremely grateful for all the
uh the success and the things that work
but i'm also frustrated that we can't
just be like let's just create this
aspirational thing and it just happened
in it
to be financed in the way that we wanted
to be financing just like here's this
thing that we thought of and we spent
all this time on
um
yeah but for me that desire's not going
to go away when i when i think about
this list of people
it isn't like oh man i have regret about
choices we've made i just think i'm
still very young i have a lot of life
left
and the way that i'm going to position
um
myself in the future is to get in the
way of more of these things that i
admire in these people right you want to
actually engineer your life in a way
where you move towards the things that
are inspiring so it might be frustrating
but i think that that frustration is
just us being honest about
you know um
i mean i
get tired of seeing myself on the
internet
to be perfectly purpose
perfectly frank about it you know what
i'm saying she's like yeah i
i kind of wish i didn't have to
constantly be in this in multiple
streams of content in order for this to
work
but burnham doesn't have to do that but
burnham doesn't have to make an internet
video today
to be talked about and to be appreciated
and you may say well you guys don't have
to either and i'm not saying that i'm
burnt out or anything like that i'm just
saying that i'm jealous of someone who
can be like i'm going to ball it all up
and give it to you in this way that's
not the that's not our business model
our business model is constant
contact in content
and i'm and it works and people
appreciate it
but
it
i would be dishonest if i said well i'm
jealous of the people who don't have to
do that
which leads me to my number one
donald glover
um
for all the same reasons but i think
even more so than bo burnham because
he does so many he does so many
different things so you can be like i am
going to become a musical artist and i'm
not just going to be a good musical
artist i'm going to be a great musical
artist and i'm not just going to be a
great musical artist i'm going to be a
culture defining musical artist
in a way that every person who's doing
only music aspires to
it's such a yeah but then i'm gonna have
this show that's like
an artistic expression yeah and yeah and
i'm gonna make choices on that show that
are for are you caught up i'm not caught
up on this i haven't started this this
season i i i'm waiting for the right
time to hit it so
and then everything that i just said
he doesn't
like what is what oh let's go watch
donald glover's instagram story today
it doesn't exist
because it doesn't need to i mean i
really i it's really a question like
would you do
i mean first of all neither one of us
are very active on social media
no we have but our presence on social
media is very high because the mythical
presence is very high
but like
if you never had to
tweet again you never had to put your
opinion out about anything you never had
to say where you stood on this you never
had to be here's a picture of me doing
this
ever again and you could just be like
here's the thing that i wanted to create
and you guys can watch it if you want to
would you choose that
well i feel like
the only thing like i don't really tweet
i don't really i don't really share
much i've kind of
hit a lull there's like been some times
when i'll get back into it but the
majority of the time i'm not into it so
then i just feel guilty that i'm not
like
i'm not doing enough
from a like a professional standpoint
right so to me it's about like
like it's an obligation that i'm not
fulfilling so it's more about the
feeling of not fulfilling it
uh
so i don't feel like
i have to
trade it
um
but in general
like what i trade i don't know i feel
like
when i trade
my experience right now for any of the
people that i'm jealous of
and it's i mean if you have to take a
kitten caboodle i wouldn't you know it's
yeah i agree with that uh you know it's
i mean i don't know any of these people
personally yeah you know it's like again
i you i do read things in the mr beast
profile piece it's like okay it's like
things about his existence are things
that i'm not jealous of
you know it's like when you get into the
specifics
like i don't know
bo burnham personally i don't know
what his experience is but like but even
his special came from a place of pain
right so yeah so it's like i don't agree
i
i'm in a pretty nice spot and i'm you
know
i'm pretty content like i'm i'm actually
i'm jealous of aspects of things but if
you can't pick and choose
then it's like there's no one that like
i would trade my life for it's like i
completely agree with that yeah as a
matter of fact i was telling jesse about
this i know we're getting along here but
who cares
um
i was telling her recently i was like
and i was talking to my therapist about
this too
i was like you know i you know i haven't
struggled with depression that hasn't
been i mean i have i get depressed at
times you know like anybody who gets sad
or kind of gets down in the dumps or
whatever but i haven't struggled with it
like a diagnosable
well yeah i wouldn't call those things
depression then but yeah yeah yeah but
i just was talking to him recently and i
was like you know i keep sort of
there's been multiple times over the
past couple of months where i'm just
like i'm happy
you know and i and i tend to not be very
satisfied person this might i'm very
very driven like to a maniacal point
and i get a lot of satisfaction out of
coming up with something and then being
and then like i'm gonna go after that
like i'm geared in that to that
so i don't there's not a lot of time
where i just stop and think oh
i'm happy i've got it really really good
but there's just been a number of times
recently where and i don't know if it's
like with you know lot getting ready to
go to college and it's like our you know
our family dynamic is about to change or
whatever
um but just kind of just recognizing
that like man like
if there is a universe if there are
really multiple worlds and there's other
versions of me out there who made other
decisions at different points and ended
up in different places
i just can't imagine
many of them
being better than this you know i reckon
i recognize that how
great everything has worked out so i i
completely
by by talking about my frustrations
creatively and how like i love the fact
that donald i'm jealous of the fact that
donald glover and bo burnham don't have
to have a social media presence because
their creative presence is so
overwhelmingly significant i'm jealous
of that but i completely agree with you
that i'm not saying i want to trade
places with anybody on the list
yeah i think that we have
i mean we've
we've we're enjoying success
we're at a
we're at like a great point in our
careers
where there's things there's
the relationship with our fans and the
relationship
the relationships that we have with each
other and you know all of it is kind of
like we're in a we're in a good spot
uh personally professionally um
i think another part of it is
if you focus on the professional part
we do have
a lot of freedom and power to say
okay we can re if there's anything we
want to go after or restructure or any
anything that we want to do it's like
we
have the ability to do that like well we
don't have the ability to do anything we
want to do
and have
you know like to work with any actor
we want or to get any film we want made
or like to to stretch our legs
creatively in any way possible but we
have
compared to
most people in an artistic field we have
so many more options and so much more
power
to to uh
to orchestrate our lives you know and i
think that that level of autonomy is
uh
is a blessing isn't it it's not a
guarantee to find ourselves in this
position is i mean i think
i'm very grateful for that
so in in a sense like when you say well
you can you could play a bass while
djing it's like it's just a crazy thing
to be able to say and yeah it's funny
that you said it but it's also true
you know it's like we're at a point in
our lives where
we do have
the the freedom to pursue things
and and and
we don't really have to get too
too much buy-in
for for things that we would want to go
after
yeah you know um so
it's really on us
we don't need to ask permission
we need to ask forgiveness well you know
it's it took in an effort to wrap it up
i mean i i think that
the thing that i the way i've been sort
of framing it and this is with the help
of
my therapist
is as you if you're a busy person and
most people are busy
you kind of have to ask yourself
you know
am i putting
life-giving things onto my plate or like
taking things onto my plate and am i
taking life taking things off of my
plate and then putting life-giving
things on and you know as an individual
what those things are right
um because even in a even in a
profession like ours in which it's like
hey it kind of is it feels like it's all
fun and games
to an extent because we do this we have
these we're ridiculously lucky and
fortunate to have the jobs that we have
and to be able to do the things that we
do but even we can still make decisions
to put a bunch of life-taking things
on our plate that things that don't
bring us joy that things that seem
obligatory
things that don't get us into creative
flow whatever those things might be
and so i think
going through a list like this to me the
things that i identified with in the
majority of these people is what i would
envision being a life-giving thing to me
right
so
it's a way to kind of evaluate all right
again we're still very very young and
there's and like you said there's a
there's so much opportunity and there's
and there's so much freedom
but what kind of decisions are you going
to make are you going to make decisions
that are fear-based
that are designed to uh fulfill some
obligation that you put on yourself or
an obligation that you think exists out
there from someone or or fans or
whatever
or are you going to make decisions to
do things that give you life
enjoy
and turn you into rick rubin in 20 years
right
like what's your version of
a satisfied
old man
full of equanimity
if you haven't listened to the
kendrick album i mean it's it's about
his personal journey a lot of it through
therapy and like at the very end
the
you hear him say i chose me i'm sorry i
chose that's the hook
yeah i chose me i'm sorry and it's uh
i mean there's a lot going on there and
i don't fully understand all of it but
yeah it's like uh
there's also some eckhart tolle in there
so
you should check it was on the list i
didn't mean to make the right
i have listened to this i've listened
through through one time
um it's not i mean i recommend it but
that's not your wreck that's lame to
make a kendrick lamar album your
recommendation um
just do it uh know it man my
recommendation is uh
do not share socks with your children
okay
all right
you know enough said
i mean if you if you haven't started yet
if you if you think to yourself like
yeah but we kind of like we wear the
same socks
do not let it begin okay i'm in the i
the only thing in my life right now a
fungus on your foot has nothing to do
with fungus
it has to do with the availability of
socks
because yeah when you're all taking
socks from dad's drawer because you
block and you shepard
do not you know they have to do their
own laundry in our house that's how it
works
and
which means the laundry doesn't get done
their laundry doesn't get done and so
there's somewhere in their room there's
an abyss of socks most of them mine and
so i i hate it i hate that i do this i
go on the internet and i buy more socks
instead instead of making them wash
their clothes which
i mean i don't know man it's just
brought the only thing in my life right
now that's not making me happy is the
sock situation and i feel like it's all
my fault and so now the only thing i'm
going to do is i'm going to buy more
socks and i'm going to create
the drawer in my room that they
currently use is going to be the dummy
drawer they don't they're not going to
listen to this episode
and that's where they're going to get
their socks which will run out very soon
i'm creating a new spot that i'm not
going to tell them about where i
actually keep my socks oh yeah you don't
want to be the dad that has to do this
so just don't begin sharing socks your
life sucks man 1-888 earpod 1
next week hashtag your biscuits
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]